Steve Jobs was an incredible visionary who
transformed the computer, mobile and music
industries.
He single handedly brought Apple back from
the dead and transformed it into one of the
richest and most influential companies in
the world today.
But here's some things you might not know
about Steve Jobs and Apple.
1.
Steve had amazing attention to detail, one
day he called Google to tell them the yellow
gradient in the O of their logo, wasn't quite
right.
2.
Steve persuaded PepsiCo president John Sculley
to become Apple's CEO in 1983.
By telling him "Do you want to sell sugared
water all your life, or do you want to change
the world?".
The irony is John Sculley later fired Steve
Jobs from Apple in 1985.
But Steve Jobs claimed that being fired was
the best thing that ever happened to him,
because it lead to the most creative period
of his life.
3.
During Job's time away from Apple Computer
he was a busy bunny, he started a brand new
computer company called NeXT, and bought a
small, but soon to be large, animation studio
called Pixar.
Pixar later went on to strike a game changing
deal with Walt Disney and created the legendary
"Toy Story", on which Steve Jobs was executive
producer.
NeXT was eventually bought by Apple and Jobs
returned to Apple in 1996.
3.
Jobs was obsessed with the quality of design.
On his death bed he refused to wear his oxygen
mask because he didn't like its design.
4.
Apple sell approximately 10 iOS devices per
second, that's not including their Mac range.
5.
Apple Computer was started by two college
dropouts, Steve Jobs and his buddy Steve Wozniak.
They launched the company from Steve's family's
garage in 1976.
6.
Apple's factory in China, where iPhones are
manufactured, employees 230,000 people.
There have been 18 suicides at the plant.
Suicide nets are now in place to prevent any
more employees' from taking their own lives.
7.
The very first Apple logo showed Isaac Newton
sitting under a tree, with an apple about
to fall on his head.
8.
Apple made the first mass-market digital camera,
called the Apple QuickTake.
It was launched in 1994 during Steve Job's
absence from the company.
It had 0.3 megapixels.
The camera was a massive failure and Jobs
removed it from the market upon his return
to Apple.
9.
The first Apple computer, appropriately named
the Apple 1 was released in 1976.
It cost $666.66.
Only 200 were ever made.
10.
The third founder of Apple, Ronald Wayne sold
his share of the company in 1976, for a measly
$800.
His shares would be worth an estimated $35
billion today.
11.
Apple is worth $624 billion.
In fact Apple now has more disposable cash
than the entire U.S. Treasury.
12.
If the iPad were manufactured in the U.S.
Because of the major difference in wages and
running costs, it would cost a staggering
$14,970.
13.
Jobs was born to an Arab father.
He was later adopted by a middle-class couple.
Clara and Paul Jobs and grew up in California.
14.
Steve's first job was a video game designer
for Atari.
He used the money he earned from Atari to
travel to India for a spiritual retreat in
1974.
It is rumoured he returned home wearing traditional
Indian clothing and had a shaved head.
Jobs then became a Buddhist.